who is the biggest forex fraud after
finding out how big forex fraud was on
the internet and on Instagram
particularly I decided to deem some of
the bigger Forex accounts featuring all
the tell-tale signs of a scam money cars
giant claims of wealth like this little
did I know how insane some of these
scammers really were and here are our
challengers today we have Randy Nelson
trade Forex Marcus
Michael T Stoll Barb and of course
passive FX investment I'm going to be
telling each of them that I have a
sizable amount of money and then ask
them how much money I can expect to make
if I invest it with them hopefully by
the end of this we can answer who is the
biggest forex fraud but before we do I
want to educate you a little bit about
forex scams Forex means foreign exchange
and usually when people use the term
they're talking about trading currency
scams of this nature come in many shapes
and sizes but generally it involves wild
promises of guaranteed returns that's
the biggest red flag as well as usually
the tell-tale sketchy brokerage you've
never heard of under absolutely no
circumstances should you trust these
people I don't care if your brother
mother father daughter promises that
they made money with this system
whatever foolproof or not stay very very
far away because sometimes these scams
will immediately run away with money and
sometimes their Ponzi schemes where
they'll give you maybe a little bit of
your money back in the hopes that you'll
invest more with them because you get
greedy and eventually they will run away
with your money but I think that's
enough of an intro rant let's go ahead
and catfish some scammers
so I actually got this idea from a guy
named Raphael Palmdale who made a
YouTube video claiming to make like a
million dollars or more in a single week
last week's results 1.8 million guys
this was just last week it's false no
way
not this time it's totally me and
obviously I think this is complete BS
but I wanted to join his chatroom to
find out what is he promising his
students if he's proclaiming to be the
Guru that's making millions over a
single week
well I joined up and very quickly he
told me that 15% monthly returns were a
realistic goal and if I only invested
five hundred dollars with him you know
it's realistic to think that I'd have
two million dollars in five years you
know from five hundred dollars which of
course is completely ridiculous and
ludicrous if you know anything about the
market and average returns and this is
an instant red flag but it got me
thinking is this the craziest thing that
people hear when they talk to these fake
gurus or are some of them offering even
more which led me to the point of this
video which is trying to get the wildest
claims I could possibly get from the
biggest scammers to do this I posed as a
complete forex newbie who's grandma had
recently left me an inheritance of
$100,000 to play with and you know I
don't want to work again laptop
lifestyle make me money guys make me
money on repeat I went to the scam ESP
'pl offered them all my money and asked
them hey how much can you make me if I
give this all to you now I messaged a
lot of these scammy looking accounts but
ultimately only four of them messaged me
back and here's what I discovered the
first thing is the absolutely insane
financial claims in their bio I know
it's not instagrams job to like police
this stuff but somehow it feels to me
that this should be illegal sixty
thousand dollars in less than 30 days
but all right let's get into it our
first guru we're gonna be talking about
is Forex Marcus now forex markets the
first thing he does is ask me where I'm
located I say the US he says oh I'm from
the US but I'm based here in love
and he's working for an investing
company he pretty quickly tells me that
you can earn over ten thousand dollars
on 80% profits with little investment
capital he then tells me he's going to
be managing my account for me and that I
have to invest in it using Bitcoin money
gram or Western Union aka just put all
my money using a non-refundable method
into his account to trade for me but
don't worry he says I will be getting my
profits in seven days
sure profits no delay to which I ask
okay what's the brokerage will be using
he responds what the hell are you
talking about what's brokerage what's a
brokerage I try to explain to him and
then he says to me
are you the one to teach me my job but
here's my favorite part because then I
tell him my whole sob story and you know
how much will I make if I make a hundred
thousand dollars and he tells me it will
earn me 1 million rams apparently every
7 days 1 million rands is actually a
currency it's a South African currency
and it's funny that he would default to
rands because he says he's from the US
and a trader in London so it's funny
that he's using a South African currency
you know in just everyday speech so this
guy's probably actually located
somewhere in South Africa but when we do
the conversion basically he's promising
us $50,000 every 7 days given $100,000
in actual you know USD 50% of my
investment every 7 days already we're
doing way better than Raphael which I'm
very excited to see next up we have
passive FX investor his name is Smith
from Washington he's a certified broker
with seven years of experience trading
and investing in flat crypto currencies
in the Forex and stock market I tell him
I'm looking to make money and ask him
about a story he had on his Instagram
account where he promised people monthly
payout of 38,000 dollars a month I asked
him how much investment for that he says
a hundred thousand dollars to which I
say well hey you know just as a check
can you can you link me your broker's
license because obviously you're
certified broker of course
and here's where we get to reflect he
says oh wow that's private information
hmm no it's not if you're a registered
broker-dealer confirm ation so he
proceeded to call it broker check which
is a way you can look up any registered
broker in the United States and oh my
gosh surprise surprise they had never
heard of him chuckling Lee when I
confronted him on this all of a sudden I
was blocked surprise surprise on to the
next idiot so we're going to get to our
third guy here Randy Nelson trades I
tell him hi I want to join make money he
says do you know anything about forex
trading or Bitcoin mining I said watch a
lot of YouTube so kinda he goes okay I
can help you trade and make good profits
weekly or monthly basis then we'll share
profits 8020 you're taking 80% while I
take 20% so already he's saying let me
take your money
I'll trade for you right but then get
this he says if you invest $300 you'll
get three thousand five hundred forty
six dollars weekly and this is ooh mwah
this is where we get to the stuff we've
been waiting for three hundred dollars
get three thousand five hundred forty
six dollars weekly ten thousand five
hundred dollars monthly ladies and
gentleman can we do a little bit bit of
math on that for a second that is a
return of that is a monthly return of
three thousand five hundred percent
oh my god this is what I've been waiting
for these gurus have nothing on these
Forex guys these Forex guys are nuts
they don't even care don't even care
about making it sound plausible oh yeah
invest $300 get ten thousand five
hundred monthly by the way look at this
guy's account man look at this guy I've
never seen a more trustworthy face in my
life did ya that's a guy who can make
you three thousand five hundred percent
in a month on your investment and of
course he charts it out for me to show
me that hey actually you can invest more
than that if I invest two thousand
dollars I will get 17 thousand dollars
back weekly all in weekly profits and a
hundred percent guaranteed payout as a
shirt you can also monitor your account
whenever you want so guys no rants two
thousand dollar investment hey make
thirty one thousand dollars monthly easy
money I say well what will my returns be
if I hit big and invested 100k my
grandma left me a sizable amount of
money I'm hoping to never work again he
says well if you invest with a hundred
thousand dollars get ready boys get
ready get your body ready for this one
your profit will be ready for the fakest
brewery we've ever seen in fake-a-roo
history 1 million fifty two thousand
dollars with seven days of trading
I said well you just blew my mind that's
amazing he said Lowell I did as if he's
surprised that that is a surprising
figure so I said wait a second
before I decide the winner it's looking
like this guy's gonna be the clear
winner by a country mile let's go ahead
and go to our fourth and final
contestant or as I call them the Forex
scammer with a heart because this guy's
name is michael stuhlbarg and i'm tired
at this point of you know running these
guys along so i just say let me get
straight to the point my grandma just
died and the old bag left me a hundred
thousand dollars to play with and i
thought if i play my cards right I could
probably never work again how much if I
invested 100k with you do you think I'd
make and he says to me to my surprise
you have to start low and
see the income okay that's my advice
think about it
have you ever heard of a scammer say hey
wait well we don't get me all your money
at once hey this is too easy
I don't want you to make it too easy on
me let me let me go low and slow and
actually at this point I was like maybe
this guy isn't a scammer maybe I have
him wrong so I say I try to bait him a
little more I go I want to go on all in
how much can I make
he says don't go all this so finally I
say well how much do you think I should
start with 300 USD so I'm thinking okay
maybe this guy if he doesn't what he's
not crazy so I asked what are the
average returns of that twenty-seven
hundred dollars in three days into
twenty seven hundred dollars USD in
three days so he is a scammer but he
feels bad about taking my grandma's
money he take oh my gosh he's a scammer
with the conscience he feels bad about
it hey don't give me all your money just
give me $300 don't give me hey hey I
feel bad about taking all your money so
actually don't give it all to me this is
the most amazing thing I've seen so of
course you know it's not crazy to think
that you could be making essentially a
thousand percent in three days but don't
give me too much money about it for that
which kind of left me at a crossroads
because actually when you crunch the
numbers
Michael T stole bark are our scammer
with a conscience actually offers the
most return on investment so the biggest
scam but he also refused to take a
hundred thousand dollars so I'm going
after crown just gonna have to make a
little audible here call it for Randy
Nelson trade okay Randy Nelson trade is
the biggest forex fraud on the market if
you want $1,000,000 in seven days of
trading just invest $100,000 with this
guy dude my hat's off to him obviously I
will not be giving this man a hundred
thousand dollars but if you ever wanted
to know what these Instagram accounts
are willing to promise you for that
sweet sweet dough to get that sweet
sweet grandma money that is how much
they willing to offer so I hope this was
educated
for you to see just how these scams work
right and I hope you guys do not fall
for them this was obviously educational
it was to laugh but either way that's
we're gonna leave it today I hope you
had a lap I hope you learned something
and as always don't forget to smash like
and subscribe thank you
[Music]
[Music]
feeder lifestyle was really difficult